how was last night at this door so a
triplet couldn't be more packed couldn't
be more like Sam's gonna do stuff that's
Kraus Sam's gonna do this oh yes he's
great it was a great crowd no birdy a
little birdie told me you had to follow
Joey Diaz and I knew that before you're
going on I thought I thought about it
and I was gonna text you and I was like
Oh Brian's the only guy on that lineup
you can follow Joey did probably that
guy right now with you the materia do it
yeah because I've seen Joe's material
and it slaps debase he was he was
destroyed I'm never the lights go dark
there's no one I'm never ever there's no
another woman tonight whatever worry
about following just I've been doing it
too long but no last night I watched him
in from the back he was getting applause
everything and I was like this I was
like getting this is gonna be this is
gonna be interesting this this for a
second I was like this might be nervous
a child no never get nervous because I
just know even though she you know yeah
90th but it was interesting but then it
was great they were an amazing crowd
they're one of the best crowds I've had
that's what I the best sets I've had you
know I want I was supposed to be
original I was on it and then Samuels
thing and make a man like kid comes the
day I want to do it but you Sam yeah
yeah you gotta say how matter respect
but but a part of a part of it was I'm
high-energy and I have my genius but it
was they were [ __ ] great what a great
crowd yeah it was a good show we did you
watch - I never watched from sight no
matter who it is I don't want to oh I I
you've been fighting like I think I
don't like the the the TV on over the
freights previous because if a guy gets
super [ __ ] up like that everywhere
that's different like now you don't want
that in your head but I sort of went
ahead if the guy before me he's eating
[ __ ] bombing yeah and then you go out
like I don't do my thing you do your
thing regard yes what do you think
regard I was never able to really watch
stuff Davidoff because I loved his
rhythm so much his rhythm was so jazz
like and different that I would get
caught sometimes in that loser G yeah
and it didn't work for me yeah you know
I'd be like I'd be doing some [ __ ] well
when you guys when we do life on the
kids are you I always remember before
you a lot of energy a lot of energy lots
of yes yes yes go out there with energy
yes they're all two now especially in
the beginning yeah first starting up you
you hit him with
everything you've got you don't give
them you don't give them time the huge
part of like performance is about
domination like it sounds weird but a
huge part of performance is coming out
and saying this is how it goes
[ __ ] your lines you're about to
listen to this me lying to him yeah you
were listening to what that classical
that's adorable time time to turn this
dial to punk rock and [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
you my mouth ready but that is a huge
part of it
domination of the audience art is
domination I've heard that started up
dude but The Comedy Store because this
podcast thing and it's become a global
market The Comedy Store is so packed
every day seven days a week
it was always Sam Tripoli and I were
talking about the old days when the
counter was love a dark Hall with 12
people in the original room I [ __ ]
Friday you know it's weird though it's
and uh so I can endure concern about
this who were door guys at the chemist
or Dracula but the thing is is um the
the because the improv is great place to
but every top podcasts which economy
podcasts everybody talked about the
Comedy Store yeah everyone talks about
dockside so it's like created this
persona now we're all famous yeah I was
like well there's great lineups not the
same lineup there's nowhere that the
same lines economy store but there's
great lineups at the improv some nights
the factory is great line outs but by
SAS is great lines but it's just not
like the comics cuz all the top
comedians and podcasters talked about
that referenced economy stores TV shows
comedy stories just and Mitzi shore
never really actually got to see it
dealers not not the way it is now she
never got to see it become this massive
tourist attraction because there was a
time when I had heard that they were
actually thinking about selling the
entire property mode yeah if they wanted
to they could have gotten twenty five
fifty dollars because they build a hotel
on that
oh dude and the shrine Oh make sure
their credit was like math or a [ __ ]
comedy primetime location there it is
Eric Griffin I hung with him last night
he's so funny he's greatness right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing
been doing
[Laughter]